mohamed et kennedy sont retournés faire
un tour aujourd'hui dans le port de
catane le naufrage des derniers jours a
replongé ce malien et cet ivoirien dans
le drame qu'ils ont eux mêmes vécu il ya
un an quand ils ont décidé de tenter
l'aventuré de l'immigration clandestine
mohamed traoré a lui-même échappé de peu
à la mort lorsque la pirogue dans
laquelle ils prenaient place avec 80
autres personnes a chaviré en pleine mer
il n'a dû sa survie qu'à l'intervention
des gardes-côtes italiens
à chaque fois qu'elle se croit le murat
se rappelle à ces jours là parce que
moi-même sur pan asia mais j'ai eu la
chance se courir des migrants
clandestins embarqué à bord de ces
quarts et et de marais ces charrettes de
la mer c'est aujourd'hui le quotidien
des gardes-côtes italiens
une situation qui désole le commandant
de la garde côtière en colère contre les
hommes à l'origine du trafic
assimilables but you guys options et
louis moulin
nous avons affaire à des organisations
criminelles ni plus ni moins dit il
ce sont des gens qui met volontairement
en péril la vie de tant de femmes et
d'enfants
jean ping la présence de plus en plus
nombreuse d'enfants parmi les
clandestins est une tendance qui
inquiète sérieusement l'organisation
save the children qui est de la prise en
charge des survivants nous savons qu'une
centaine d'enfants sont morts lors du
dernier naufrage du gema parking et les
quatre qui ont survécu sont tous
traumatisés
l' ong qui recueille les témoignages des
enfants note un comportement de plus en
plus brutale de la part des trafiquants
qui n'hésite pas à menacer les migrants
avec des armes
certains enfants dit elle ont vu des
gens se faire jeter par dessus bord et
oui mais les puissants mohamed aussi par
des armes à feu des trafiquants utilisé
pour forcer les clandestins à monter à
bord d'embarcations déjà trop plein à
20k le coup d'armoires allard papa pas
bien ça peut paraître parfois peuvent
qui peut pas traiter rhin mohamed est
encore aujourd'hui traumatisé par son
expérience
s'il a choisi de témoigner c'est pour
décourager les autres de faire comme lui
c'est plus lourd
l'édifice est plus dramatique qu'on
passe les 28 pays de l'union européenne
ont prévu tenir jeudi un sommet
extraordinaire sur le problème de
l'immigration clandestine
objectif donner plus de moyens aux
missions de sauvetage en mer plus de
ressources aussi pour tenter d'arrêter
les trafiquants très mince consolation
pour les familles des disparus
la mort de leurs proches aura au moins
servi à cela faire réagir l'europe face
au drame qui se joue chaque jour en
méditerranée et si jean françois
bélanger radio-canada catane en sicile